solche bilder prägen unsere vorstellung
von demenz aber demenz hat viele formen
und stufen nur heilung gibt es keine
es gibt demenzkranke die noch ein fast
normales leben führen und solche die
auch im vergessen glück finden kann ist
höllisch woche ist besteht los das ist
darum erst dich
[Musik]
überzeugt ist die menschen state
warriors qualität habe sie emotional
richtig ab ob die und fred rot sind seit
47 jahren verheiratet das bist du das
vor wie viel das ist ein 26 26 ist das
sei sagt ja seit vier jahren ist hedi
roth alzheimerkranke zuerst war sie nur
hier und da vergesslich jetzt beginnt
ihr auch die vergangenheit zu entgleiten
ich mir live auch situation als
persönlichkeit sich sukzessiv der andere
ich sind stress wenn sie merken dass es
eine rednerin
ja ja ja ja sagt sich die meter drüber
nein es ist das was ich jetzt stellt sie
den stress ist merkt dass man sie schon
immer erinnere was kann ich dann immer
[Musik]
der fitte 82 jährige fred rot ist zum
hausmann geworden
rund um die uhr sorgt er für seine frau
alles liegt jetzt an ihm
die 72-jährige hedi roth spürt noch dass
sie vieles vergisst dass sie eine
unheilbare krankheit hat weiß sie nicht
mehr
das ziel an mitleid und hat sechs altes
durchsichtiges real weg und nach 1900
1000 dass gott oder aber eigentlich das
über haben will oder und stinkt das dass
er innegehalten muss haufe leit déi dem
etwas viel
ja ja ja ich möchte mich immer dann wenn
es händler und schlechte tage
da komm ich auflagen sollen es auch
nicht ungeduldig zu behandeln und ich
war schoss ist nicht dass sie das
bewusst macht sondern es läuft einfach
denn mit zu erledigen und das sind immer
so wenig abschnitt also mit dach ich
immer weniger und sie beschreibt wie so
einen relativ erwartungen
das gehört für mich ist natürlich in
sachen schlimm dass der zustand sehr
jung
dass ich noch eintragen die punkte steht
als ich zu hause aber natürlich sehr
sehr stark wie kein generieren die mine
tätig weiter auf einen film machen
zwei jahren mal schuhe zu
das langsame aufgestellt ist natürlich
wirklich gut drauf nicht für
kommunikation und persönlichkeit
es wird immer schwieriger zu verstehen
was sie meint probieren sie beobachtet
oder sie macht aber das ist wenig
wildenloh in das loch in frage ich sie
magische handy was dann
fred roth nimmt nur wenig hilfe in
anspruch
im pflegeheim war seine frau bis jetzt
erst zweimal kurz als er sich ferien
leistete
uns geht es nur irgendwas weiß nicht es
gibt alternativen zum pflegeheim tages
und nacht kliniken zum beispiel im
pflegezentrum baden hierhin können die
demenzkranken von ihren angehörigen für
einen oder mehrere tage gebracht werden
[Gelächter]
das pflegepersonal mit zentrumsleiterin
doris knecht sorgt dafür dass sich alle
immer wohl und geschätzt fühlen kontakte
pflegen sich am leben freuen auch sie
ist alzheimer krank wie rené müller
ehemaliger arzt gehilfin fährt trotz der
diagnose vor einem jahr noch ganz
selbstverständlich auto
sie ist in einer frühen phase ihrer
demenz und sie kann und darf noch vieles
dass es ihr so gut geht liegt vorwiegend
an zwei frauen an ihrer freundin elsie
preise und ihrer ärztin in der memory
klinik vermutlich vergangenen jahr da
hero und problem ist sie dass sie im
alltag ist ihre bühne richtig
funktioniert hat
für diese gewaltige stresssituation sie
will sie ja eigentlich ganz genauer
menschlich und wirklich für sie das
extrem schwierig sich dass sie mit denen
fehlleistungen konfrontiert worden ist
das hat für sie bedeutet dass sie auch
wirklich depressiv wurde iris seelisch
ganz schlecht an musikalisch der erste
schritt ist dass ich nur während der
sprach stunden arbeitgeber angemeldet
haben und sie 100 prozent arbeitsunfähig
geschrieben haben will ich haben dass
nämlich eine verantworten
in einer arztpraxis dass man vergisst
dass der mann schon lange
das war nicht zum ersten mal und lima
gemacht dass ich während der upgrade
100% sofort arbeitsunfähig schritte
haben
irene bob ist verena müllers begleiterin
in ihrer krankheit regelmäßig besuchen
die beiden frauen die ärztin in der
memory klinik zur kontrolle
mach deine us-flaggen verena müller
wohnt im selben haus wie ihre
freundinnen während diese arbeitet
besorgt sie die beiden haushalte vieles
kann die sehr exakte und zuverlässige
frau noch so gut wie früher
und plötzlich stößt sie an ihre grenzen
kann etwas nicht mehr was man zuletzt
erwarten würde jetzt zwar spießig nehme
ich weiß einfach nicht was kommt
[Musik]
der waschmaschinen
erst dank herrschaft wieso weiß ich
jetzt das nehme ich so musik rätselfrage
oder wieso muss ich jetzt überhaupt
delegiere also jetzt macht sie eine
freundin
ich mache dafür für beide und 1000 aus
eric sagt verena müller weiß wie
alzheimer endet sie hat jahrelang ihre
mutter mit dieser krankheit betreut
deren zimmer ist seit ihrem tod
unverändert geblieben
dieselbe krankheit zu haben obwohl diese
nur selten erblich ist war ein schock
wäre ich doch nun könnte ich sterben und
im widerschein unter den bedingungen und
optimierter gegangen ist wir halt dann
doch noch relativ schnell ist es doppelt
werk sie das überhaupt könne zu
akzeptieren
sie müssen wir aber sie haben sie wie
lambert ja noch extrem gold oder damit
ich bin ruhiger und gelassener sache
nach und versucht das beste aus der
situation zu machen
das geht mir eigentlich ganz neue
qualität so schlechten tag hat sich das
medienhaus sind schlechte tage sind
junge leute ist es ziemlich spontan
ihren geburtstag drückte das humanitäre
braucht es ist so in das züge rote sich
sehr darum mit den torlosen aber ich
einfach nicht und ein trip in die knie
zwingt
fünfmal
aber es macht total ausgeglichen
es kam uns im moment geht und das ist
einfach nur hilflosigkeit
ihre freundin sie tut sie nie auf
defizit aufmerksam machen
sie bringt mir fordert zum beispiel wo
sie zeigen wie toll sie noch hoch und
wie toll sieht der haushalt macht das
ganz wichtig sie dort abholen wo sie
stark ist und hilft ihre so dass die
depression kommt
ich glaube wenn nicht wär es
wahrscheinlich wirklich
so wie es jetzt ist also als ich glaubte
wirklich einfach will ich gebe ihr adobe
stück stabilität sie wer sich also haben
wenden und die stützenden faktor
ja wo sie einfach sicher regelmäßig
wiederholt die ärztin in der memory
klinik mit ihren patienten den uhren
test und eine serie weiterer tests so
lassen sich verschiedene funktionen des
hirns überprüfen
irene bob versucht dabei immer den
patienten ein gutes gefühl zu geben
verena müller ist in einer so genannten
phase
die meisten aufgaben löst die 61-jährige
noch korrekt anderes korrigiert sie mit
ihrer intelligenz und genauigkeit wie
dieses zögern in der räumlichen
wahrnehmung eine flüssigkeit zwei herzen
die kapsel stieg sie auto fahren aber
ich muss sagen im moment hätte jetzt
danke informiere ich sie nicht begangen
wenn sie das persönlich gut muss im
alter von über geschmack der abfahrt
möglichkeit oder weil ich zwei weiß der
dalai lama als oberhaupt der tibetischen
dank der frühen diagnose und behandlung
geht es verena müller guth und das kann
noch jahre dauern
sie weiß aber dass die krankheit trotz
medikamenten letztlich nicht aufzuhalten
ist
doch sie ist nicht allein mit ihrer so
einfach unsere freundschaft wo es
verbietet irgendwann wird vielleicht
auch verena müller in ein tages- und
nachtzeit rum müssen
möglich dass sie es dann gar nicht so
schlimm findet bei den patientinnen und
patienten jedenfalls ist dieses zentrum
beliebt hinterholzer kommt gerne hierher
für den 82-jährigen alzheimerkranken ist
das fast wie ein arbeitsplatz seine frau
martha holzer braucht dringend erholung
hier kann sie für zwei wochen die
verantwortung für ihren mann und seine
vielen medikamente abgeben
7 das stimmt genau jetzt gegangen
zuspricht
hmm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hinterholzer ist ein fröhlicher aber
anstrengender kranker martha holzer hat
die ferien von ihm nötig bitteschön
hilse es ist das verrückte wenn sie in
es so rund und auch singen und günter
holzer hat seine frau schon vergessen
er macht seine arbeit er hat immer etwas
zu kontrollieren und zu planen sie auch
sehr ungeduldig es ist nicht so dass das
alles immer so ruhig ab genau sich die
den militärischen fragen die alle
emotionen sie hier
und das einzige was mir immer rettet ist
mein garten
das ist sowas nich rettet ist das sicher
weil ich komme dann nicht mehr an wie
vorwand ja nicht dass man das holz
brauchen und sie sich das spiel zu
verwalten
validieren heißt die methode die
zentrumsleiterin doris knecht anwendet
dem kranken immer recht geben und ihn
immer ernst nehmen
hans heinrich schmidt war rektor der uni
zürich und theologieprofessor er und
seine frau sind große musikliebhaber vor
zwei jahren dirigierte er zum letzten
mal ein konzert vor vier jahren wurde
beim heute 72-jährigen alzheimer
diagnostiziert
wir denken doch alle wenn wir unsere
hirnzellen so fleißig nutzen können uns
diese krankheit nicht passieren
doch alzheimer kann jeden treffen die
persönlichkeit und das berührt show
immer ganz speziell an so mancher zu mir
ich sprach stummfilme team ist einfach
ganze bespitzelt sie dass er als
theologieprofessor als brillante redner
zunehmend probleme hat mit der wort
finde großes thema sagt sie sind wieder
schafft zur musik hat das langfrist
dirigiert und wann täter über
kompensationsmechanismus diskutiert und
die nada sicher irgendwo user schritt wo
wir mit dem patienten dass wir das
möglichst lange erhalten
aber wenn es nie magath auch der schritt
mit den anderen und ich zeige dass
einmal sehen sie das ist jetzt ihres
herren ii und das ist es noch mal sehen
wie die und bex über fragen wie dem
bericht
das sind hohl und das ist mit
flüssigkeit gefüllt und bettelt an dich
nicht so da sie das innere der schwarz
sind
ich denke das haben wir runter das ist
da ein normaler hirn aber da ist es
einfach geht's los sagt was bin ich ganz
schön ist hier nicht das ganze und gut
sei dann ist das gut
sehr gute koordination auf anraten von
irene bob hat der professor den ganzen
kanton zürich erwandert seine touren hat
er auf einer karte rot eingetragen das
schafft er noch spielend nur das reden
darüber ist schwierig
durch krankheit zum großen wanderer
worden
ja das kann man so sagen will es einfach
basis für das muss dann auch wieder raus
wo oder ab und zu hinter ihm einige
politiker jetzt die ganz recht
das ist schwierig wir machen es
probieren etwas was sie jetzt immer mit
107 wegziehen
die berichte können
das leben
das ist jetzt einfach darf magath und
das moderne lieder wiedererkennen und
jetztige die natur könnte jetzt doch
natur das begleitet sie ja es und bauen
einen verrückten zu fördern
sie wissen die zahl der unter 2
das war es wieder überlegen heißt 334
die heute als 24
[Applaus]
also danke ich bin extrem er wird zum
diagnosestellung ich überhaupt kreis
plattform ich bin absolut offen und alle
total müde
der krankheitsverlauf ich mich einfach
weil ich ja das spiegelbild wenig
rohstoffe oder patienten
das war nichts positives aussteller und
wir dürfen negative oberhof das kannst
du besser gott geredet die euphorie
habilitation oder die manns obwohl es
bewusst ich es grad
es gibt nicht mehr wo ich und aber das
heißt eigentlich möglichst völlig vom
tisch
sie haben dutzende bücher geschrieben
übersetzt was ist wichtigster der wand
das ist also der punkt geht relativ jung
gemacht hat nämlich so groß und so ist
es brauch dass ich jetzt genau das
problem
ja das ist das problem ganz falsch sagen
ob ich das ist dann wirst du dich noch
eine dank sehr viel schwerer auch sehr
viel schwerer
nicht nur für vertreter nicht mit der
sbb zum beispiel oder mit rouge wo nicht
immer ganz sicher bin ob sie so stark
also wenn ich jetzt darüber singen und
nur da
ich weiß nicht wen ich wenn ich würde
wirklich ein tolles geschenk machen
ja ja ich brauche das könnte sich das
macht aber das ist doch einmal das
akzeptiere dass man dass man sehr
traurig sie bin eigentlich nicht ruhig
berührt eigentlich nicht aber dass durch
sie haben den unglaublichen optimismus
im tages- und nachtzeit raum baden wird
an der linde heiden die hier ein paar
tage in den ferien war von ihrem
erholten ehemann abgeholt isabella ist
traurig alle werden abgeholt
sie muss noch warten auch martha holzer
kommt erholt aus den ferien zurück
[Musik]
vorläufig schafft martha holzer dank
diesem zentrum noch den spagat zwischen
betreuung ihres mannes und eigene
erholung
und isabelle meyer wird von doris knecht
immer wieder aus der depression geholt
das ist renate huber hätte auch allen
grund sich von der pflege ihres mannes
zu entlasten
aber sie ist erst 59 sie fühlt sich
stark genug ganz für ihren demenzkranken
man da zu sein musste sie doch um diese
liebe ihr halbes leben kämpfen
sie lernte ihren mann mit 17 kennen
geheiratet haben die beiden aber erst
mit 40 extrem das große böse sparpläne
glätte und sie 0 führen und auch sie
interesse an der natur nach den ersten
glücklichen jahren kam der schock der
erkrankung
zuerst machte das herz nicht mehr mit
und dann wurde marcel huber innert
weniger monate ein anderer mensch er
wurde aggressiv fast bösartig dann
wieder depressiv verdrängt es ist für
mich ist es ganz schlimm sieht sich
welche seite sie geistig für nötig weil
die sturköpfe truppe nicht macht haben
und des court central und xii zu wählen
überlappen
können sie sich daran erinnere dass sie
sich einwählen und jetzt gab's am besten
ist das thema weiß dass mich das
zahlen tut mir so mehr macht hoffmann
ihre lebensqualität
also was für mich stimmt
der cashflow es geht sind sie noch wild
lorig er hat das schon wenn die 10 wird
als sie wird der reform bett lege der
ganztag wahrscheinlich und machen so
aktivieren und das programm macher mit
dem motto die welt gerufen oder sagt
jetzt gehe ich auf terrasse bis 60 meter
das nicht beliebter fachbezogene 17
also was ganz wichtig ist dass ich
gemerkt dass er dort für druck mit seite
sie ganz strukturierte täglich liberal
alles usa und das freche turnus sich
hunderte wieder sofort aggressiv ob es
dann könnte mich immer verhalten trick
und persönlichkeitsstörung im forderung
sie ständig von der partnerschaft
und er hat ja nur der alzheimer
erkrankung sondern die finanzberatung
sie das mir extrem auf die
spannungsvolle aufgegangen sind wo das
veränderte verhalten und die verändert
die persönlichkeit ausgelöst hat als
renate huber ihren mann wegen seiner
herzprobleme ins spital brachte
wie ist der herzspezialist ihn weiter an
die memory klinik und irene pop für
marcel huber ist jetzt der moment für
ein neues gehirn scanning gekommen
produkte doppelt merkt an dass sie über
krankheit ganz konkret was auf einen
zukommt und vor allem weniger mit er
einfach nur funktioniert wir legen jetzt
sie mir hilft von mir was sie gewollt
oder und es gibt wahnsinnig dass das
referendum
ja
nicht nicht massiv ausgeprägt aber dass
die frontale bereich ist im vergleich
mit übliche anteile mit betroffenen aus
der minderung beträgt und das ist jetzt
ihres hirning das vorstellen was man
einfach sehen dass jetzt davor dass hier
nie schrumpfte gegenüber jenen sei nicht
schön und darüber dass gewisse routine
wenige stunden davor
doch die die klar ist da und das ist ja
genau das was sie störe erklärt dass
sich die persönlichkeitsveränderung
verhaltens vorantrieb die impuls ich
stehe das von tallinn ist wie ein
koordinator für ganz viele heutige und
leber und sie impulskontrolle das minus
könnte und genau da hat sie ja problem
internet oder wie sie zu mir die kameras
liefen
weil die ärztin genau weiß woher hubers
hirn noch gut funktioniert schickte sie
ihn trotzdem es in den internet corner
des spitals dort lernte er wenn auch
mühsam und mit vielen notizen noch mit
fast 60 einen computer zu bedienen
so kam marcel huber zu seinem neuen
hobby im internet schaut er den
flugzeugen in kloten beim starten und
landen zu stunden kann er damit zu
bringen
ihr interesse sei sehr groß beschäftige
toni moser beschäftigen extra möglich
computer gar nicht das ist wenig lebt
derzeit 40 bewusst sie auf jegliche mir
nicht und das ist auch richtig so
[Musik]
qualität vor eben fühlt sich durch
verbesserte dabei durch eine vielfalt
und haben diese versuche mit mehr
streicheleinheiten zu windig und david
mc dass du gegen gut dastand schön dass
sie das machen so dass das miteinander
besprechen von minen gefühl dass sie
jetzt den angriff gefunden haben der
frau andere ebene die neuen ski
sie waren bin oder wenn er die nacht
sogar ins bett und strichen bis heute ob
ich spiele irgendwie das tut ihm gut
und da geht es über sie reden dass ich
für sehr wichtig dass sie gehört was ich
mit ihr reden lässt
mehrmals pro woche kommt nachbar sünden
läsker zu hubers auf besucher als eine
art therapie hund für beide mir das gar
nicht vorstellen so schön
so wie sie das gegen die haie sorgen
aber das will der us militärs das
erfahre ich täglich in relevanz hat lanz
qualität und es kann ein paar zusammen
bringen
das war zieht wo man gemeinsam früheren
und verbraucht hat sich intensivst im
moment erlebt und ein moment von glück
gehabt aber im moment von der
abgrundtiefe tour der kreditbereich
speck von der konkreten fall da sie oder
gar zu tun die situation aber es geht im
moment vom glück und die radlager und
erlebe derzeit dass das und das ein
schönes erlebt
doch irgendwann kommt für die meisten
demenzkranken trotz guter betreuung der
moment in dem ein pflegeheim sehen macht
auch das muss nicht so schlimm sein wie
es sich viele vorstellen in der
demenzstation des pflegezentrums baden
darf jede so sein wie sie will aufstehen
wann sie will alle dürfen frühstücken
wann und wo und wie sie wollen
in gut geführten heimen ist das heute so
und davon gibt es einige
ja
jede wird dort abgeholt wo es ihr gut
tut jede bekommt menschliche zuwendung
mit genügend personal ist das möglich
das sind
dafür läuft das auch so an
jede darf ihre noch vorhandenen
fähigkeiten nutzen
[Musik]
die monte foods sein
je mehr das personal auf die bedürfnisse
der demenzkranken eingeht desto
zufriedener und ruhiger sind diese das
spart letztlich nicht nur mühe sondern
auch zeit
der große garten ermöglicht es die
menschen mit farben und gerüchen zu
stimulieren
ja ja ja ja
alle dürfen sich nach ihren
möglichkeiten mitteilen und finden auch
zuhörer findet sie es mir erzählen auf
deutsch wie sie wollen
[Musik]
dies alles findet in einem ganz
gewöhnlichen öffentlichen pflegeheim
statt
es arbeiten nicht mehr personen dort als
anderswo
und es kostet nicht mehr als anderswo
aber es braucht genug personal und es
braucht vor allem gutes personal
nur so können demenzkranke auch in
zukunft glücklich sind
[Musik]